من تاريخيا في البلاد وان القطاع الصحي في
حاله انهيار من جهتها اعلنت نقابه الاطباء
السودانيين ان نحو 60 مستشفى توقفت عن
العمل او في سبيرها الى ذلك بسبب
المواجهات بينما حذرت منظمات دوليه من
اوضاع انسانيه وصحيه ماساويه في السودان
اذا لم يتوقف القتال
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما مدى التدهور الذي
الت اليه الاوضاع الصحيه والانسانيه في
السودان جراء المواجهات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع وما مدى ادراك طرفي النزاع لهذا
التدهور وما حجم جهود المبذوله لتخفيف
الاثار الانسانيه للقتال على المدنيين في
ضمن تركز المواجهات في المناطق الماهوله
بملايين السكان وما امكانيه استجابه طرفي
النزاع لظروف الانسانيه الصعبه التي
يعيشها المدنيون وما وسائل الضغط المتاحه
عليهما لتعليق القتال ووقف التدهور
الانساني بالبلاد
[موسيقى]
ابتداء من وزاره الصحه الاتحاديه الرسميه
في السودان مرورا بنقابه الاطباء
السودانيين والمنظمات الصحيه المحليه
والاقليميه والدوليه توالت التحذيرات من
انهيار القطاع الصحي بينما تفاوتت
التقديرات بين من راى الانهيار واقعا
بالفعل وبين من يراه وشيكا يلوح في الافق
فبحسب نقابه الاطباء السودانيين ووزاره
الصحه بولايه الخرطوم فان نحو 60 مستشفى
في البلاد خرجت او على وشك الخروج من
الخدمه جراء المواجهات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع وان بعض هذه المستشفيات اصيب بشكل
مباشر بينما عجزت التواقم الطبيه عن
الوصول الى مواقع عملها وانهكت الطواقم
العالقه في المستشفيات منذ اندلاع القتال
السبت الماضي وبالنظر الى ما تشير اليه
الاحصاءات من اصابه نحو ثلاثه الاف شخص في
المواجهات فان اعباء جديده تضاف الى
القطاع الصحي المنهاك اصلا ويتعرض مصابون
بامراض الفشل الكلوي وسرطان والقلب لخطر
الموت المباشر بسبب الاوضاع الجديده
ومع برود تقارير عن موجات نزوح من الخرطوم
باتجاه مختلف الولايات اكدت المفوضيه
الدوليه لشؤون اللاجئين امام بين 10,000
وعشرين الف لاجئ سوداني وصلوا الى تشاد
قادمين من دارفور هربا من احتدام القتال
وبموازاه التردي الحالي المريع في الوضع
الصحي بحسب وصف المنظمات فان تحذيرات من
احتمال تفشل الاوبئه بسبب انتشار الجثث في
الشوارع والنقص الحاد في المواد الغذائيه
ومياه الشرب والكهرباء تهدد بايام عصيبه
لنحو ثمانيه ملايين شخص يعيشون في الخرطوم
وحدها
[موسيقى]
لمناقشات هذا الموضوع معنا من الخرطوم
اللواء الدكتور محمد جمال الدين المستشار
في الاكاديميه العليا للدراسات الامنيه
والاستراتيجيه ومن الخرطوم كذلك معنا صالح
جمعه الكاتب والمحلل السياسي لكن قبل ان
نبدا نقاش مع ضيفينا نرحب من جناز
بيباتريكي يوسف المدير الاقليمي لافريقيا
في اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر ليقربنا
اكثر من واقعي الاوضاع الصحيه والانسانيه
في السودان بسبب المواجهات بين الجيش
والدعم السريع مرحبا بكم جميعا سنبدا معك
اذا باتريك يوسف عندما تقول وزاره الصحه
السودانيه ان القطاع الصحي على وشك
الانهيار او يعيش في حاله الانهيار كيف
يتجلى ذلك على الارض عمليا
شكرا لاستضافتكم
هالكلام اللي سمعناه من الوزاره واكيد عم
نسمعه من قبل رؤساء الاقسام مدراء
المستشفيات هو منه مبالغ فيه اكيد وقتها
يكون في شحب المواد الطبيه
وكثره طلب
نظرا لعدد الجرحى اللي عم يتوافد على
المستشفيات من الطبيعه انه القطاع الصحي
ما يقدر يعبي الالتزاماته او يودي يجيب
نتيجه اكبر
بالنظر للطلب العالي بنفس الوقت ما بدنا
ننسى انه هالمستشفيات مع قادره تحصل على
طاقه كهرباء غذاء
للمسؤولين الطبيين عدد من الامور لازم
تتحل بسرعه قبل ما نوصل لمرحله ما نقدر
بقى نرجع نرد الامور على مكانت عليه قبل
النزاع المسلح
ما هي هذه الامور
اكيد بدنا نوصل المساعدات سريعه وطريقه
هيدا الشي طبيعي كل المستشفيات بدها محصول
من المواد الطبيه مواد الاغاثيه مواد
الجراحات جراحات الحرب وبنفس الوقت بدنا
نامن كمان ان الطاقم الطبيه يقدر يوصل على
المستشفيات وهذا اللي عم نعانيه اليوم
كلجنه دوليه للصليب الاحمر او الهلال
الاحمر السوداني هي عدم امكانيه خروج
الطواقم الطبيه حتى فرقنا منا قادره تطلع
على الارض لانه بذل
الوضع الامني يلي عم يزيد شده يوم بعد يوم
طيب اعلن امس عن هدنه انسانيه في السودان
طبعا لم تصمد ولكن هل سعادتكم على الاقل
بجانب معين في امكانيه ايصال هذه
المساعدات التي تتحدث عنها
انسانيه بدها
تكون تاخذ مجراها بده يكون عندها الوقت
اللازم والتحضيرات اللازمه يلي صار كان
فتره كتير قصيره وما بتصور حدا محترم
الوقف اطلاق النار على الاقل مش بالمناطق
يلي مفترض بدنا نقدر نوصل للمستشفيات
فللاسف ما قدرنا نستفيد منها وبعد كمان
بعد مره ماني مؤكد انه وقت اطلاق النار
اخذ حيز التنفيذ مثل ما مثل ما سمعنا
بالاعلام فبتامل املي فعلا انه يصير في
هدنه حقيقيه على الاقل لفتره قصيره
ليسمعوا للناس اولا تطلع تلاقي الامور يلي
بتخليها على قيد الحياه من اكل وشرب بنفس
الوقت عم نحكي خاصه لطوائم الطبيه لتقدر
تامن المستلزمات اللازمه ونقدر على الاقل
كمان نقدر نشيل الجثث من الطرقات عم نشوف
الصور بالعالم مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي او
على نشرات الاخبار وهذا الشيء لانه منو
ممكن لقد ازعناها للتو وموضوع الجثث
المنتشره في الشوارع وهذا ايضا يعني شيء
طبعا له ايضا تداعيات كبيره على مجمل ما
يحدث الان في حاله استمر القتال سيد
باتريك ما هي التداعيات ما السيناريوهات
المحتمله
عم نحكي نحن اولا واخيرا بالعاصمه يلي
فيها اكثر من خمسه سته مليون نسمه عم نحكي
بعاصمه وين الناس بتعتمد على على المرافق
الصحيه مرافق العامه لتقدر تاخد خدماتها
وين في عددا امكانيه وصول بسهوله اذا كمل
هالوضع على ما هو عليه اولا اكيد راح يكون
الضحايا من المدنيين عددهم اكبر بكثير
لانه القتال عم
يتمخولي وبنفس الوقت القطاعات اللي
بنشوفها بغير دول خضعت للاسف لنزاعات
مسلحه توصل لانه منا قادره تودي الخدمات
اللازمه كميه المياه اللازمه تمضخ للبيوت
مستشفيات وعدد كتير كبير من المرافق يلي
للاسف منا ما راح تقدر تكمل على ما هي
عليه اذا ما وصلنا المواد الاغاثيه لتقدر
تعبي المخزون وتكمل بالخدمات اللي لازم
طيب الان ونحن نتحدث هناك ايضا اعلان عن
امكانيه تجدد الهدنه
الى يوم الخميس المقبل في حال صمدت هذه
الهدنه الجديده هل هذا وقت كاف من اجل
يعني محاوله تدعيم القطاع الصحي في
السودان
براي ستنا الكريمه كل ثانيه مهمه بها
بالوضع الراهن كل دقيقه وكل يوم يقدر على
الاقل يعطي لمحه امل بصيص امل للاشخاص
اللي محتاجتها انا اليوم باخذ للمندوبين
ومتطوعين الى الاحمر اذا بينعطى 24 ساعه
او اكثر اكيد الامكانيات حتكون الوقت عفوا
ما راح يكون كافي ولكن بيقدر نقوم بنقدر
نقدر نعمله نقدر نوصل للمندوبين الاشخاص
لافاده اتصال ببعضها كمان تقدر في عدد من
النشاطات بنقدر نعملها بس مثل ما عم نقول
لازم نشوف انه الهدنه بتاخد حيز تفوت حيز
التنفيذ وتحترم من قبل الاطفال
اشكرك جزيل الشكر السيد
باتريك يوسف
السيد باتريك يوسف المدير القيمي افريقيا
في اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر حدثنا من
جناب شكرا جزيلا لك
نعود الى ضيفينا من الخرطوم اللواء
الدكتور محمد جمال الدين المستشار في
الاكاديميه العليا للدراسات الامنيه
والاستراتيجيه والسيد صالح جمعه الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي ايضا من الخرطوم مرحبا
بكما دكتور محمد جمال الدين هذا الوضع
الانساني المتردي الى درجه كبيره في
الخرطوم هل يشكل باعتقادك عاملا ضاغطا على
القوى المتحاربه اليوم
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
الاخت الكريمه
ورمضان كريم
وحقيقه
الان ما يجري في السودان وخاصه في العاصمه
الخرطوم يعني هو امر مؤسف جدا
ولاول مره العاصمه القوميه او الخرطوم
يعني تشهد مثل هذه الاحداث الداميه وهذه
الاحداث البشع
وحقيقه فيما يقتصد يعني هل تصمد الخرطوم
يعني
بشكل هذا فيما يعني بعض الهدنه التي
انتهت اليوم الساعه السادسه مساء
اخرى بدات من الساعه السادسه مساء اليوم
ستنتهي ان شاء الله غدا في نفس الوقت انا
لا اظن ان هذه الهدنه يعني
ستشغل كثيرا
التي يحتاجها هناك الكثير من الناس الذين
يخرجون من الخرطوم يعني بعضهم يذهب
الدكتور محمد السؤال يعني نحن نسال ان كان
اي من الطرفين المتقاتلين عسكريا في
الخرطوم الان يلقيان بالا للتردد الوضع
الانساني والتداعيات الانسانيه على سكان
المدينه هل هناك من يابه لذلك بما يدفعه
الى وقف القتال ووقف اطلاق النار
والله انا انا اقول صراحه منذ اعلان
الهدنه امس لم يتوقف القتال يعني منذ
اعلان الهدى لم يتوقف القتال نحن نسمع
اصوات ذخيره ثقيله واصوات ذخيره متقطعه من
هنا وهناك
ولا ارى ان هناك
[موسيقى]
احتراما كام
لا للمعلانها
من الضرائب وبالتالي هذا يشكل هذا يشكل
هاجسا كبيرا للمواطنين
ولان المواطن في طيب سيد صالح جمعه دعنا
نستمع الى رايك يعني التحذيرات الدوليه
تتوالى من التردد الكبير وتداعيات
الانسانيه الكبيره
بسبب هذا القتال هل تعتقد ان هذه
التحذيرات يمكن ان تشكل مدخلا لوقف هذه
المواجهات العسكريه
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
اول
حاجه
معطل لمدينه الاشتباكات اللي ممكن استمرت
اليوم السبت
وازدادت سوءا من كل يوم
وعدد من المستشفيات وعدد من الوضع الانسان
ونتيجه هذا ممكن يكون نقابه الاطباء ولجنه
الصليب الاحمر وعدد من المنظمات الدوليه
التي تعمل في المجال الخدم الانساني
ممكن يكون رغبه هذا العمل وممكن قدمت
تقارير واضحه هذه التقارير في نقابه
الاطباء السودانيه الا خروج عدد اكثر من
33 المستشفى و17 مستشفى اخرى قد تخرج من
هذه
من الدائره وكذلك الصليب الاحمر ظل يراغب
لاكثر من كم يوم عن هذه التحديات الممكن
والان اصبحت حتى البنيه التحتيه حتى
البنيه التحتيه للمياه والدنيا التحذير
الكهرباء وغيرها اصبحت مجره
احتمال يكون مجرد تحديد كامل جدا جراء
الانطلاق الاشتباكات
سؤال السؤال هذا التردي الكبير في الاوضاع
هل يمكن ان يشكل مدخلا لكي يتوقف القتال
العسكريا نعم نعم نعم هذه الاشياء هي ممكن
تؤدي
الخدمه واللي هي لانه اول حاجه الظروف
الانسانيه زي ما ذكرتها حديثي الان هنالكم
مناشدات كبيره جدا للمجتمع الدولي في
مناسبات داخليه الان اصبحت الرحلات ونحن
نشاهد فيه في الجزيره الان وفي القنوات
الاخرى ان عدد كبير جدا من مواطني الخرطوم
وحوالي 50 مليون نسمه الان في اكثر من
نسبه كبيره جدا الان هي قاعد تخرج من
الخرطوم مسافره للولايات لكن هنالك نقاط
معينه لابد ان نتفق عليها او تتفق عليها
الاطراف في العمليه ولا حاجه الان يستفيد
الهدنه لابد ان يكون في اليات قويه جدا
يراقب هذه الهدنه وكذلك اليات الرغابه لان
هي اللي ممكن تساعد الصليب الاحمر تساعده
المنظمات الدوليه تساعد الانسان ذاته
للوصول لامكانيات الاستفاده من فتح
المسارات الامنه اللي ممكن تقود الانسان
الى الى جراء العمل وبعدين يكون عمل كذلك
تفاوضي مرحله في السن بين المكونات
المتغاثه على مستوى الميدان دكتور محمد
جمال الدين هل هذه الاليات متوفره حاليا
في السودان اليات تنفيذ او الاشراف على
تنفيذ هذه الهدنه والتاكد من ان الجميع
يلتزم بها
لست متاكدا من هذا الامر لكن
ليس اليات تراقب هذه الهدنه
ولم نرى يعني حتى ولم نسمع يعني حتى في
الاذاعه والتلفزيون
تهتم بهذا الامر امر يعني مراقبه يعني
مجريات هذه المده التي تمت منذ امس منذ
امس وبالتالي
هذا يضيف ثقل اخر على يعني على تدهور
الاوضاع لانه ليس هناك مراقبه وانما هي
مراقبه ذاتيه من
الطرفين الدعم السريع كل راقب امره بامره
ولم نرى ولم نسمع باليات يعني موجوده
لتراغب هذا الامر لتقتل تقارير توضح من
الذي يعني خلق هذه الهدنه ومن الذي يعني
تمسك بمبادئ هذه الغده وكذا
سيصالح جمعه وهذا ما اريد ان اسال السيد
صالح جمعه عنه بغياب هذه الاليات التي
تراقب الهدنه ومن يلتزم بها كيف للطرفين
ان يلتزم
[موسيقى]
وممكن يكون كذلك
الرئيس الجزائري والايجاز وهو المدنيه
وعدد كبير جدا من الدور حتى السعوديه
والامارات وغيرها من الدول الممكنه الان
ظلت ترغب هذه العمليه عن كذب عن وقف
العدائيات
هي الان يفترض دخلت حيز التنفيذ هل هذه
الاليات التي تتحدث عنها هي موجوده الان
ام يجب العمل على ايجادها
اول حاجه الاعدادات هي موجوده الان وهنالك
بيانات صدرت من الطرفين من الدعم السريع
وبيان صدر من القوات المسلحه ان هم
الطرفين الان ملتزمين الالتزام كامل بهذه
وهذه الالتزام نتيجه للتواصل ما بين
القوتين من الناطق الرسمي باسم القوات
المسلحه او الرئيس المعني لغات الدعم
السريع تم التواصل عبر وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي الاثنين هم اثبتوا بانهم
هيستمروا في عمليه الهدنه لكن ظلت في خروج
هذه الطرقات اخر
ت اخفياء الساهمت في انقطاحه
ظروف جديده خارج ان تكون الجريده اللي
ممكن نعمل ان تستمر اقاسه الانسان الان
اصبحت القضايا الانسانيه موجوده في في على
سطح
الصراعات وربما يكون في تفلتات الدستور
الولايات وكذلك حتى على مستوى المناطق
الطرفيه نحن الان نتحدث على الخرطوم لكن
هنالك ضرر كبير جدا الان في شمال دارفور
وفي جنوب دارفور وفي عدد كبير جدا من
المناطق الان اصبحت الان غير امنه خارج
الخرطوم اعاني من هذه الظرف الانساني
وبدعاني من غياب الامن الكامل ولذلك انا
برى ان لابد من الصمت هذه الاشياء اذا
استمرت بشكلها قد تعود الى حرب قبليه قد
تعود الى الى عمليه داميه بين هذه
المكونات على مستوى السودان لان المنحنى
بتاع الحرب الان هو قد يقود قد يغوت انا
عراقي فهذه الكذب ان قد يعود لان
الوجود الان
والسرعات الموجوده في الولايات والصراعات
الموجوده في الاطراف هي قد ذات تشبه
العمليه بتاعت الصراع الموجوده على مستوى
الخرطوم وقد تؤثر على المجتمعيه على مستوى
الداخل دكتور محمد جمال الدين باعتقادك في
هذه المرحله ما هي المخارج من اجل وقف هذه
المواجهات العسكريه بشكل نهائي
والله انا انا ارى اختي الكريمه انه
المخرج الوحيد هو يعني ان رفيقي وايجاد
والمجتمع الدولي بهمته يعني الى الحديث
يعني بالطرق الدبلوماسيه المعروفه
والتواصل مع الطرفين بصوره مباشره
يعني الايقاف هذه الحرب
او الهدنه لفتره يعني اطول تمثل الناس من
يعني من الاستمرار في حركه الحياه العاديه
يعني او يعني التواصل مباشره من الاتحاد
بقيه الاطراف الاخرى التي تدخل في
صار
ت يعني اللجنه ايقاف النار بدون يعني بدون
ان ان يعني ان يدخل في هذا الامر بصوره
جاده
هل هذه المساله يعني ما بين الطرفين هي
حيكون التنازع ما بين
المؤسسه العسكريه الجيش وبين الدعم السريع
حتى
يعني يعني بهذا الفهم الواضح ان هناك
اليات
يعني
تبسط بعض الاشياء التي يجب ان يتم بها
الطرفان ليست هناك
مسميات لكن ليس هناك يعني
صالح جمعه كيف تقيم وتيره عمل الايجاد
التي قدمت
يعني
اقتراحا بتقريب وجهات النظر بين
المتقاتلين
التوفير هذه المبادره الايجارات لاول حاجه
للظروف
تجمعنا بهذه الدول وكذلك الامكانيات اللي
ممكن تمتاز
والتشابه بينها وبين السودان وحتى على
طبيعه الصراع الحاصل ما بين دوله جنوب
السودان انا
الاكثر حظوظا الان في حل الازمه الموجوده
في داخل السودان لان الصراع السابق اللي
كان دارس
بين الرئيس الفاكير الحالي هو عضو
ايجادبه دكتور مشار المساهم الكبرى كانت
الحل الجزري لمعالجه هذه الازمه من
السودان ولذلك انا هذه الحلول قد تجدي وقد
تغورنا الى حل بين الطرفين والوصول الى
حجز سلمي نموذ النافله مرحله السياسيه
والتحول ديمقراطي حقيقي طيب دكتور محمد
جمال الدين ايضا صدر اليوم بيان عن سفارات
الدول الكبرى يدعو الى وقف القتال وقف
المواجهات العسكريه والعوده الى طاوله
الحوار الى اي مدى يشكل هذا البيان كذلك
عام لا ضاغطا على القوى
ان هذا البيان ايضا يعني سوف يكون له
مكانا يعني
بين الطرفين لانه يعني
امدها
من الوصول في نهايه الامر الى التداول
والى التباحث ليست هناك حرب
ستحل اشكالا مهما كانت هذه الحرب ومهما
كانت مهما كان المنتصر لقد حاربنا في
الجنوب قرابه الخمسين عاما ولكننا في
النهايه لم ننتظر فقد انتصر الجنوب الحرب
لا تقدم حلولا فانا افتكر الان كلا
الطرفين
سيصغي باذان يعني انا افتكر
واضحه جدا في
تعتقد ان الطرفان سيصغيان الى هذا البيان
ما الذي يعني ما هي اليات الضغط عليهما من
اجل وقف القتال العسكري
والله ليست هناك
ولكن انا افتكر يعني كل الطرفان يعني
الجيش والدعم السريع يعني مهما كانت
المساله
الى هذا العمل لانه في النهايه هو ندائي
انساني اكثر من انه هو يعني ضغط سياسيا
على الطرفين فانا افتكر سيكون هناك تجاوبا
انسانيا يعني وخاصه من القوات
يعني الى يعني
لهذا الامر وسيستفيد منه الطرفان في
التعامل ان ارتكب بايجابيه لحد ما يعني
حتى على ادنى يعني ادنى مستوى التعامل سيد
صالح جمعه باعتقادك كيف تتلقى قوات الدعم
السريع هذا البيان الصادر عن السفارات
الكبرى وهل ستلتزم بما ورد به بالدعوه
التي تضمن هذا البيان بوقف القتال العسكري
والعوده الى طاوله الحوار باعتقادك
قوات الدعم السريع سيد القائد محمد حمدانو
ممكن يكون في البيان الصادق لقوات الدعم
السريع عن الهدنه كان ظلهم ملتزمين حسب
الخطاب المنظور البيان ملتزمين بالعمليه
الهدنه حسب الخطاب اللي ممكن ذكر او توزع
في على مستوى التواصل الاجتماعي الان هم
قوات الدعم السريع والقوات المسلحه
والرئيسين البرهان والسيد الرئيس
هيلتزموا بهذه لان اصلا احنا لا يكون
السودان
على المجتمع الدولي وهذه واحده من الاليات
في منتصره عليها ولا لا يمكن ان نعيش
بعيده من المجتمع الدولي التي ظل يرافق
هذه العمليه عن كسب عطي
الدولارات التي تسند اليها ونحن ندخل يعني
نحن نطوي اليوم الخامس من هذه المواجهات
العسكريه ما المؤشرات التي
تدعم ما تقوله
المؤشرات التي تدعم هي واحده منها العمليه
بتاعت الهدنه اللي ممكن تعود الان لو
تعاملت هذه الهدنه بالطريقه اللي ممكن
شكلت لها بالطريقه اللي ممكن تضمن
استمراريه العمليه الانسانيه قد تعود هذه
الهدنه
الى عمليه
تفاعل جديد في العمليه بتاعه في عمليه
الاستمراريه في عمليه السلام والتعايش وقد
تضمن للمجتمعات المجتمع الدولي او
المنظمات الدوليه التي تعمل في هذا المجال
مساحات
تدخل من خلالها من الطرفين لمعالجه هذه
الازمه وهنالك الداخليه انا بفتكر غير
الجهود خارجيه هناك الجهود داخليه الان من
الحاجبين على مصر وكذلك بعدد كبير جدا من
من من
اصحاب الغير ممكن هم منتمين للعمل في
السودانيه الان تنكر هذا الامر وهي الان
في وساطات رقمي واستخانه السلاح
وجود لكن صوت الحكمه لا يكون بعيد عن
القيادات الموجوده في الاطراف الطرفين لان
كلهم الان هم مسؤولين لان البيت الابيض في
المناشد الاخيره هنالك البيت الابيض كان
يحمل البرهان وحمي التي مسؤوليه عن حمايه
المدنيه الدبلوماسيه العايدين وكذلك عدد
من الدول اللي ممكن الان ظلت هي هي تحمل
تحمل الرئتين البرهان وحمايه مسؤوليه
كامله عن حمايه المدينين في السودان هي
واحده من اليات الضغط على هذه
المجموعات دكتور محمد جمال الدين
في المرحله المقبله في ضوء يعني تفاؤلك
تفاؤلكما بان هناك ما
يؤشر الى ان الطرفين
سيتوقفان عن القتال عسكريا
انا انا ارى يعني
سيناريو هذا كالاتي انه سيكون هناك يعني
ستكون
مراقبه من المؤسسات الاقليميه ومن ثم عبر
الحدود على يعني مع بعض المؤسسات الدوليه
الامم المتحده وغيرها
والتزام هذه او انتظام هذه
الاليات للمراقبه
يؤدي الى مزيد من التواصل مع اطراف النزاع
الموجودين في السودان وهذا ايضا معه يعني
مع
المحاولات الجاده الداخليه من الحكماء
واهل الحكمه يعني واصحاب المصلحه
الموجودين داخل السودان
[موسيقى]
ويعني هذه الهدنه هي ايضا مؤشر ايجابي من
الطرفين
لنهايه
الامر
من الخرطومه لواء الدكتور محمد جمال الدين
المستشار في الاكاديميات العليا للدراسات
الامنيه والاستراتيجيه وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا
من الخرطوم كذلك صالح جمعه الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي وقبلهما باتريك يوسف المدير
الاقليمي لافريقيا في اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر كان ضيفنا من جنيف مشاهدينا
بهذا نصل الى ختام هذه الحلقه من برنامجهم
ما وراء الخبر ولكن تغطيتنا للاحداث في
السودان مستمره
[موسيقى]